And now to your scout master.
We sometimes find, because America is so big in our media and in our movies and everything, that people kind of assume that we're the same,
It gets really irritating.
What's even more irritating is when I speak to people and I say, yeah, but speaking with somebody from Scouts Australia, they have Scouts.
Yeah, they have Scouts.
It wasn't even invented by an American.
It wasn't invented by an Australian either.
This is podcast number 170.
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
First off, as always, let's take a look at the mailbag.
We heard from Steven Jensen who said: thank you again for your service to our youth.
I think the podcast and the blog are reminding people in Boy Scouts everywhere what the program is supposed to be.
Thanks, Steven,
Thanks for being in touch
And I really appreciate the kind words there.
David Ballard is with Austin, Texas, Troop 9..
And he says: as a new scout master, a couple of years ago I ran into your podcast and started listening to them. from the start
I found it would be a great help to me in putting everything into perspective.
Thanks for the great resource for Scout Masters.
It helped me get started and has influenced how I do my job as a scout master.
Thanks so much, David, once again for the kind words.
Glad to have you listening.
I'm glad you're finding things useful.
Jamie Humphries is an old friend of the podcast and the blog
And he's also the Scout Master of Troop 4277 in Flugerville, Texas,
And he wrote in in part to say it's been a crazy new year.
I just welcomed 14 new scouts from Weeblows this spring,
So it's been a fun start.
Again, all your info has helped tremendously.
Thanks, Jamie.
I enjoyed your story about the going to the campereen things
And I'm glad that you're still finding what we're saying useful
And I appreciate the kind words.
Before we go on with the mailbag here, let me note that this is podcast number 170..
We should probably play a fanfare or something.
A while back, a listener and a reader asked if there was any way for them to donate
towards offsetting some of the financial costs of the podcast.
I never really considered that an option before.
This is a free service that's offered to volunteer scouts
And as soon as you begin to get finances involved, things get very complex and complicated
and overlaid with all kinds of strange things.
But it requires a fair amount of time to produce a podcast and videos and things like that
and create content for the blog,
And there are financial realities involved in what needs to be paid for
to put it all out there on the web,
And I'm very touched and I'm very thankful that some people have expressed a desire
to help with some of that.
So here's what we're going to do.
There will be a voluntary subscription in which you can financially support
the efforts of ScoutmasterCGcom.
This is not a charitable donation or anything like that.
This is a voluntary way to subscribe to the blog and the podcast.
If you find what we're doing useful and you think it merits some financial support
through a voluntary subscription, we've made that possible through PayPal
And if you go to the blog at ScoutmasterCGcom, you'll see the about link
in the menu there
And if you'll go to support the blog and podcast, you'll find a link on how to
make a voluntary subscription through PayPal.
Several people have done that over the past week or two
and I wanted to recognize them.
Stephen Jarvis said I've been listening to the podcast since the very first episode.
I may have missed one or two along the way,
But I've enjoyed nearly all of them and learned something from every single one.
Thanks for all you do to support Scouters and Scouts.
Thank you for subscribing, Stephen.
I really do appreciate it.
Tom Armstrong also is a subscriber, as is MJ Duff, who wrote in to say
thanks for all you do for the Scouting community worldwide.
You have certainly become quite productive over the past two or three years
that I've followed along.
Enclosed is a very small contribution relative to the benefits I receive each week.
Thanks so much.
Tony Lacaba is with Troop 581 in Bristow, Virginia, and also subscribed,
And he says: thanks, Clark,
I listen regularly.
I appreciate all your hard work.
Keep it up.
This is year number three of the podcast.
It's been a great way to virtually meet a number of Scouts all over the country
and all over the world
And I really appreciate your kind words and your gestures of support.
Well, our presentation for May at Scoutscircleorg is this Sunday, May 11th,
and that will be between 9 and 10 pm Eastern Standard Time.
Go to Scoutscircleorg to participate.
We'll have a half hour presentation by a camp director about summer camp.
That half hour presentation will be followed by another half hour of your questions.
You can participate in this live.
Go to Scoutscircleorg and you'll learn exactly how to make that happen.
As I told you last week. ScoutmasterCG now has a YouTube channel.
You can find us at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
Last week we put up a video that is a review of a really great little tool
called the Lansky Blade Medic,
And you should go check it out.
It's a really effective tool for sharpening knife blades.
I love it.
I got mine from KanahoCreekcom, our sponsors.
Bill Fleming was kind enough to send me one to evaluate,
And you can see how it works by going to ScoutmasterCGcom at YouTube
and look for the video of the Lansky Blade Medic.
If you have a question or a situation for the Scoutmaster's panel to consider,
get in touch with me, won't you?
You can email me, Clark at CLARKE at ScoutmasterCGcom.
In this podcast we're going halfway around the world to Australia,
where we're going to be speaking with the chair
of the National Youth Council of Scouts Australia.
I had a great time talking with Chris Nielsen
and I can't wait for you to hear the interview.
It's going to take up the remainder of the podcast,
so let's get started, shall we?
The Scout movement is forming a personal tie
between the different foreign countries.
A living force, a great brotherhood of service.
a joyous work.
Scouts Australia established a National Youth Council
about a dozen years ago, in 2001,,
and they did this to engage youth members
in advising the organization on the relevance of their programs.
I mean, what a great idea:
Actually talk to the people who are on the receiving end of the programs.
Now there are 25 members on the council
from all branches of Scouts Australia,
aged between 13 and 25,
and they each serve a three-year term.
The council is separated into four working patrols
and each researches and writes recommendations on their own topics.
The only non-youth member of the council is the advisor,
who does really not have any voting rights or anything like that.
The chair of this National Youth Council
is a full member of the Scouts Australia National Council
and has voting rights on the National Operations Committee
and the National Executive Committee.
I'm really pleased that the current National Youth Council chair
is able to join us on the Scoutmaster podcast today.
Hello, Chris.
Hi,
Chris Nielsen is joining us from Melbourne,
Is that right?
Yes, Melbourne.
Oh, okay,
Melbourne.
Yeah,
You're going to have to correct my pronunciation as we go along,
because Australian Scouting would be very familiar to us,
I think in the United States.
But let's just go through your career in Scouting a little bit, Chris.
You started out at the age of six,
Is that correct?
About a week before I turned six, because that's our minimum age.
Uh-huh,
And what are Scouts called at that level? in Scouts Australia
They're called joeys, which is the word for baby kangaroos.
Okay,
So they're really cute.
They stand in a circle and put their hands up like little paws
and go hop, help other people.
It's adorable,
Oh, cool.
Help other people hop.
Oh, I like that.
The group of joeys is called a mob,
Is that right?
Uh-huh,
I love that.
Just like a group of kangaroos,
Well, just like a group of six-year-olds.
Yeah,
You know,
It's kind of like a mob,
And that was at what was then called the sixth ringwood scout
group.
Yep,
Okay,
But then we merged with another group when I was in Cubs
and we're now called First Maroondah.
Explain to us a little bit.
We're not familiar with the group concept here.
So a group is the group is all of the sections that meet
there.
So we have joeys, Cubs, Scouts, Venturers and Rovers.
Not every group would have all five, but my group does,
And so the group is everyone who meets that hall.
and you know we have group counsel to work things out.
And then we're also within a district in Victoria.
Some of the different states in Australia work things out
differently, but in Victoria the groups are arranged
into districts and the districts are arranged
into regions
And then there's the whole Victorian branch.
It's girls and boys in the same scouting program.
Yes,
All the way from six.
We also have guides, which is like your girl Scouts,
but that is a separate movement.
Scouts itself is boys and girls.
You're in a Rover crew,
Is that right?
Yes,
Describe what a Rover crew is, because that's kind of
foreign to us. in the United States,
Rover crews are 18 to 25 year old Scouts,
So it's a little bit like the upper end of your
Venturer section.
It's relatively similar to all of the other sections,
except given that we're all adults,
So we can all drive ourselves places and we can all
do more adult things and give our own permission
and stuff like that.
Rovers is self governing,
So it means that Rovers make their own decisions.
We don't have leaders,
We have advisors
And there is, you know, a region Rover Council
and a branch or so Victoria wide Rover Council
And they make decisions about how Rovers is going to run.
And there's also a National Rover Council.
As the National Youth Council,
I work very closely with the National Rover Council.
What kind of things do Rovers do?
Do you go camping?
You go hiking and things like that.
We do all of that.
We meet sort of weekly and do different activities.
You know, last week my Rover crew was doing New Age night
And we sat there doing like tarot readings
and having heaps of fun playing with the things
and just making up funny stories about them.
You know we go and do sort of adventurous things.
My crew went ab-sailing recently.
We go camping.
Our motto is service in the Rover crew,
in the Rover section as well.
So my Rover crew runs a competition hike
for scouts in our district.
And you're also working with Cubs.
Yes,
I'm a cub leader.
My cub name is Matka, which is the seal.
No one's ever heard of it. but you know
I actually started working with Cubs
back when I was about 16 or 17
because I had to do 20 hours of service
to get my Queen Scout Award.
It's the highest award we can get before you turn 18..
And then I just kind of never left.
I really enjoyed it.
You're currently at the University of Melbourne.
Yes,
I'm studying a master of environment.
One thing I saw in your bio that I found very interesting:
you took a gap year.
Yeah,
It was a break year between high school
and before you went to university.
What did you do with that year?
I went to China as a volunteer
and I taught conversational English for four months,
So I was just 18.
And so it was challenging but a lot of fun.
And then we traveled China for a month afterwards
and then, you know, did a little bit of Europe
and came home ready to start uni.
That must have been amazing.
It was fantastic.
I mean, it was very challenging at times,
Very much sometimes. you know,
we talk about personal development a lot in Scouts
and that was a bit of a personal development moment
for me a couple of times.
You know, being alone in a foreign country
where you only speak a little bit of the language,
it was very difficult at times,
but it was also a lot of fun
and I really enjoyed learning more Chinese language
and meeting all the people
and getting to know their culture and so on a lot more.
And it's a beautiful country.
I'm sure that your participation in Scouts-
you called on a lot of things
that you learned along the way
as you went through that gap here,
All of the skills we learned in Scouting,
like you know, your initiative
and being self-reliant and facing challenges
and knowing that you can.
Okay, it's really difficult now,
but I'm sure I'll get through it
and I'll enjoy this later.
Yeah, I definitely drew on all of those skills.
Tell me about how you got involved with that
Poll National Youth Council.
We have a rotating membership,
which means we have about eight people leave each year
and then we select eight new ones
and then you're on for three years.
I applied three times.
I applied once when I was 14 and I didn't get on,
and then I applied in 2009
when I got back from China, and I didn't get on.
but I applied again at the start of 2010
and I got on, which was very exciting.
So, as I'm sure you can understand,
only taking eight people a year
and we want to cover all of Australia
and we also want to make sure that we have representation
of the different sections and so on.
Now that I'm selecting people,
we've got so many great applicants,
so it is very much a juggling act,
but yeah, so I got on in 2010,
which was very exciting.
Then you've had several different positions there
over the past couple of years.
Yes, I was appointed minute secretary
in 2010 in my first year,
which isn't that exciting.
I just took minutes.
Yes, everybody needs somebody to write down the minutes.
Then in 2011, in March, I was elected as the vice chair
and then in March of 2012, I was elected chair,
which is a two year position.
so I've got a little bit under one year left.
so I'm no longer in a patrol
because I'm a little bit busy,
but I'm sort of in charge of all four patrols-
A little bit busy, I think,
is the understatement.
You've been doing quite a bit of travelling, haven't you?
Yeah, way back in 2010,
when I applied to be on the National Youth Council,
I also, a little bit after that,
applied to be one of Australia's observers
to go to the World Youth Forum,
which was in Brazil.
so I was selected as one of our three observers.
so I headed over to Brazil
and that was fantastic.
Last year it was the Queen's Jubilee
and we're still a Commonwealth country,
so they decided to hold a Commonwealth Youth Forum
to celebrate the Queen's Jubilee.
and, again, I just applied
to be one of the two people that we sent
and I was selected, which I was quite surprised about.
so I got to go over and go to the Commonwealth Youth Forum
and also got to march in the English Queen Scout Parade
and we got to meet the Queen and Bear Grills,
which was very, very exciting,
Oh my
Yeah. I mean like meet the Queen.
we were within like a metre of the Queen
but we actually shook Bear Grills' hands,
so that was very exciting.
Just in November last year
it was the Asia-Pacific region
Scout Youth Forum and Conference
and, as I'm now in the National Youth Council chair,
I was one of Australia's two delegates-
didn't get enough sleep
because I joined the recommendations committee,
so we went to bed at like 5am one night
because we were fixing up all the recommendations
for the next day.
but it was really, really good to be involved
in the organisation a little bit.
Why should there be an organised youth voice in Scouting?
Part of it is that Scouting is about young people,
and young people know what they want,
and young people are different.
Even the other day I was at Cubs
and I was testing one of my Cubs
on her Traveller Level 1 badge,
and so one of the things she had to do
was tell me some of the good and bad bits
about four different kinds of transport,
and how she described trains and buses,
which I take every day,
was just completely different
to how I would describe trains and buses.
One of the bad bits about a bus
was that it wasn't as long as a train.
I think I understand Cubs,
but Cubs think in a very different way
to how I do.
As a rover, I probably think quite differently
to how some of the other members
of the national team and so on think.
so it's really important to have
young people saying what they want.
if we want to keep young people,
we need to make sure we change with the times.
things have changed so much
in the last couple of decades
with technology and all this kind of stuff.
I don't know about America,
but in Australia there's a lot more options
for young people as well.
Lots of schools are now implementing programs
that are a little bit more like Scouts,
and there's so many different hobbies
that people can join
and all these different sports and so on,
and kids are getting busy
because they're doing more.
so if we want to sort of
stay relevant to young people,
we need to make sure that young people are involved
in telling us what relevant is.
Let me occupy the position
of being the devil's advocate for a moment.
I'm in my mid-fifties.
I would probably be a little frightened
of youth having an active,
influential voice,
because I think what my worry would be
is that they would try to,
you know, topple over all of the traditions
and you know they would stop going camping
and start playing video games,
or I don't really get the sense that
that is what happens. though
Generally, I think you find that
young people value a lot of the same things
that a lot of the older leaders
and so on value, and it is
it's the camping in the outdoors
and the trying new things,
and young people value that just as much.
Sometimes they want to try different new things
or they want to change things a little bit.
but you know we're definitely still
going camping and the National Youth Council.
we don't often write recommendations
about changing
huge things, like
let's stop going camping
or something like that, because
we all understand that that's what
scouting is like. we've all been in scouting
and we all love that aspect of scouting.
We often write things about
issues people might have, like
bullying or something like that.
you know new badges and we talk about
maybe new programs that could be introduced,
but we often very little. we should throw this out.
we should introduce this as well.
this would be great. We're utilized quite a lot
by the National team
in terms of getting feedback
on ideas that they're having.
so they kind of go: hey,
we're thinking about doing this,
do you reckon it sounds any good?
or we're thinking about doing this,
give us some ideas on how that would work.
we're kind of the research body for Nationals,
so they'll be
asking us to go research
what we're doing, maybe what other scouting countries are doing.
so we'll sit there on the BSA website
and look up what they're doing
to deal with a similar issue, say
bullying. okay, we'll house life saving
dealing with this, house
England dealing with this in scouts,
all these kinds of things.
so we do quite a wide variety of topics.
we're not usually telling people to throw out
things that are
part of scouting, because we do value a lot of
the things that are in scouting.
sometimes we're talking about introducing new things,
just changing things to make them
a little bit more modern or relevant.
what's the dynamic between
the
Youth Council and your adult counterparts?
you have the Youth Council
and it's working cooperatively
with the Executive
Board of Scouts Australia,
and am I right in
thinking that it's kind of a parallel
to a similar group of adults?
well, we definitely work
very closely with the National team
and all of the National bodies.
I sit on a lot of them
as the chair of the National Youth Council.
they come to our conferences
but all of the people
involved in decision making
are very, very open to what the National Youth Council
has to say and we have
definitely made decisions
just in the time I've been chair
at a National level where some of the adults
in the room have gone: oh, I don't like this idea.
but the National Youth Council says
that the young people do, so we'll do it anyway.
I noted that one of the projects
that you've worked on was
in dealing with the uniform.
so Scouts Australia changed its uniform
back in about 2002
or 2003. we sort of decided
maybe it was time for a little bit
of an update, just to see
that it was okay. and you know we weren't going to say
we'll scrap it and put in a new
uniform again, but we wanted to say:
you know, is there anything that irritates you
a little bit that we could tweak a bit?
we run a survey of both adults and youth
scouting. this survey had the most responses
we'd ever had. we were so excited, although it was
a lot of work, partly because you know the magic word
uniform. I don't know if it happens
for you guys as well, but the instant you ask
about something that's a little bit
divisive than everyone wants to have
their say: oh, yes, yes, we're very
familiar with that. yes,
so the the uniform.
this survey was
really really great response rate. and
then we ran a follow-up survey as well,
because one of the
things that came out was that venturers and
rovers wanted
a female fitted shirt.
that was one of the things that came up, and
so we ran another survey on it just to make sure
that this really was like a big issue
and the national team was
very, very supportive of this. and
we're arranging to have a meeting with
person who's in charge of snow gun, which is the
company that makes our uniforms, and
discuss with him about some of the
feasibility of introducing some of our
changes. I looked at the study.
you came up with some very concrete
recommendations. the interesting thing
about the uniform report was that it was
one of the topics that members
of the council came up with. the chief
commissioner and all of our national
team were very much
yep, okay, well, this is what the young people say.
so we'll keep investigating and
they're definitely open to
the process and very supportive of
the national youth council and the fact
that you know they kind of created it, so
now they're going to listen to it. you know that the
council has existed now for a dozen years
would be some indication
of its effectiveness and
that it's that it's
actually valued. we're constantly evolving
and changing and going all right. well, that
didn't work. okay, we'll train this
that the national team was always supportive
of the council and the idea of the council,
but now that the council is getting out
there a little bit more, we're trying to be heard
a bit more. we're trying to hear
people more and and make
sure that we can spread further which
you know- the internet and facebook and all these
kinds of things really helping us
more of the general
population of scouting and more of the
you know your branch commissioners and
and all these kinds of people who are,
throughout scouting, involved in roles
but maybe not quite at the national level,
are all getting on board
with the NYC and starting
to know what we do and also starting
to really value what we're doing.
this is something that is
not just happening in
Scouts Australia. it's actually
happening in many of the
other member organizations
of the world
organization of the scouting movement.
priority number one, I think, is
youth involvement. a lot of
countries have
introduced things that are maybe a little
bit similar to the NYC.
I go to a lot of these international
events and and make friends
and then we all discuss what they're doing.
so I've chatted with
the people from Canada and South Africa
and New Zealand and England
and France and all kinds
of places about what they're
doing and sometimes we
pick up ideas. so we have
informal networks and we
send each other our operations manuals
and discuss how things are working
and then go back and go to our national
teams. like it's really helpful to go
to some of these- you know world youth forums
and stuff like that and get
ideas about what everyone is doing for youth involvement
other than my own curiosity
and the idea that
I think
my fellow Scouts here in America
would be very interested to hear what goes on in the rest
of the world.
you know this is also
kind of an encouragement to our own organization
that
this would probably be a very
good idea
and to have a more formalized
youth voice
within the BSA.
you can imagine if there's a lot of people
like me sitting around trying to figure out
what a young person
wants or what's relevant to them.
we're not going to get that right
a good part of the time.
I mean, there's always different levels,
so there's youth involvement
right down at the troop level.
you know your troop council with your patrol leaders
and things like that, and that's just
as important in youth involvement as
something like an MIC. sometimes that's more
important because it's what the young people
that we're actually interacting with
is their local troop,
and often we actually
look at some of your patrol system
and think, oh, we'll steal that.
you know we send people over to your BSA
Jamboree and they come back with all these great ideas
for how we could improve the patrol system
in Australia. so, and youth involvement
at a local level is absolutely,
really important as well.
being the chair of the NYC,
I think youth involvement at a national level
is a really important
opportunity as well and, yeah, I mean it's really up to
how the organization
can work
youth involvement. so it's all very,
very specific to the organization
and the country and things like that, but
I'm definitely
supportive of things like NYC.
well, Chris, I certainly do appreciate
you joining us on the
podcast and
we'll keep an eye on
the National Youth Council of Scouts Australia.
enjoy the autumn. I guess it's
autumn down there, isn't it? Yes,
good work, even saying autumn, not fall.
I did my best.
I really have enjoyed talking to you, Chris.
thanks so much, That's alright. thank you,
Hey. thanks for listening to this edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
here's how to keep in touch with us. read the
Scoutmaster blog at scoutmastercgcom
while you're there. you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog and the
podcast by email. you can also
subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes when you do, if you would
leave a comment or review or a rating,
and
you can access the podcast on any
mobile device through Stitcher Smart Radio
and get details about how to make
that happen at Stitchercom.
we're all over the web
in the vast panorama of social
media outlets. that's right. follow us
at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
Tweet ScoutmasterCG
on Twitter and for admittance to the
exclusive ScoutmasterCG circle, search
for ScoutmasterCG
on Google plus. there is
YouTube and Tumblr and LinkedIn and
Pinterest. we're all over the place. so
check us out at ScoutmasterCGcom
and you'll see in the upper right hand corner
links to the various
social media outlets. if that
doesn't do anything for you, well,
you can always email me.
Zoom into the late 90s with the miracle of email
by getting in contact
with me at Clark
C-L-A-R-K-E
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
Clark C-L-A-R-K-E
the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast are not
official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by
the Boy Scouts of America.
it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to Scoutleaders,
maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, here is
our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you
and group camping.
Why? thank you, sir, until next time.
Thank you.